après les mots le cliché julien caidos a
fait poser des centaines d'enfants
ce photographe professionnelle leur a
demandé de s'habiller avec un vêtement
d'adultes d'un de leurs parents
c'était une façon de parler du vêtement
à travers le prisme
de l'enfance qui est un prisme de
spontanéité de
on va dire quelque chose depuis naturel
dehors de mon travail artistique je suis
je suis photographe professionnel donc
je travaille autour du portrait d' pour
les 1 600 et des institutions je fais de
la photographie de mode aussi j'ai déjà
fait des photographies d'enfants pour
des magazines et pour des catalogues de
vêtements donc c'est vrai que c'était un
peu l'élément déclencheur de cette idée
julien caloz veux parler de leurs
projections dans l'âge adulte la
construction de leur identité 150
clichés d'enfants guyancourt toit de 6 à
10 ans réalisée dans des écoles de la
ville les enfants ils ont voilà c'est
spontanéité la dent en tout cas
continuer pose devant un objectif qui
est quand même quelque chose de plus
facile à a capté que qu'un adulte je
voulais pas non plus quelque chose de
trop figée donc c'est vrai que je les ai
pas mal guidé pour qu' il soit pas
toujours de face qui regardent pas
toujours justement c'était vraiment dans
l'idée d'avoir aussi voilà sept cette
mosaïque de portraits qu'ils soient pas
formellement tous deux face à regarder
l'objectif pas sourire ou à sourire
j'avais j'avais envie aussi de varier
les les les plaisirs on va dire de du
cadrage un projet d'exposition réalisé à
trois lors d'une résidence à guyancourt
julien caidos a travaillé avec deux
psychologues un jeu d'enfant pour faire
comme les grands qui peut donner envie
aux adultes de redevenir petit